التقت المبعوثه الامريكيه للنيجر فيكتوريا
نولاند في نيام قاده الانقلاب من دون ان
تلتقي رئيسه او الرئيس المنقلب عليه واكدت
نولاند انها اجرت محادثات صعبه مع
الانقلابيين الذين يدركون مخاطر التحالف
مع روسيا بحسب قولها وكان قاده الانقلاب
رفضوا دخول وفد من الاتحاد الافريقي
والاكواس والامم المتحده في ضوء تباين
بشان التدخل العسكري ببلادهم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولد في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات اولها ما هدف زياره مسؤوله
امريكيه بهذا المستوى الى نيامي في هذا
التوقيت ومنعكاسات هذه الزياره على خيار
التدخل العسكري في النيجر وما فرص انجاز
تهربات بين الطرفين ثم ما مغزى هذا
الاهتمام الدولي والاقليمي الكبير بما
يجري في النيجر وما الحسابات التي تحكم
مواقف باريس و واشنطن من السيناريوهات
المحتمله او المختلفه لما سيؤول اليه
الوضع فيما بعد الانقلاب ثم ما المسارات
المحتمله للازمه في النيجر على ضوء انقسام
دول جواره خلال خيار التدخل العسكري
وتباين مواقف القوه الدوليه المعنيه
بنيامى ازاء هذا الخيار
[موسيقى]
على وقع عقوبات جديده فرضتها مجموعه اكواس
على افراد وكيانات على ارتباط بقاده
الانقلاب في النيجر بعد يومين من انتهاء
مهله منحتها لهم للتراجع عن اجراءاتهم اجر
قاده الانقلاب في النيجر تغييرات بمناصب
قياديه في الجيش ورئاسه الاركان وحذروا من
اي تابعات للتدخل العسكري في بلادهم الذي
هددت اكواس باللجوء اليه اذا اقتضى الامر
ورغم الانقسامات في مواقف دول جوار النيجر
بشان هذا التدخل الا ان استعدادات قاده
الانقلاب تحسبا له تواصلت من خلال نشر
قوات اضافيه في العاصمه النيابي وجلب قوات
من اجزاء اخرى من البلاد
وعلى صعيد الجهود الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه
لحل الازمه في النيجر استقبلت انياميا
التي اغلقت ابوابها في وجه وفد ثلاثيه ضم
ممثلين عن منظمه ايكواس والاتحاد الافريقي
وكذلك الامم المتحده استقبلت مبعوثه
واشنطن فيكتوريا نولاند التي قالت انها
التقت قاده انقلاب النيجر من دون ان تلتقي
قائده عبد الرحمن تياني واضافت انها اجرت
محادثات صعبه مع قاده الانقلاب الذين
يدركون مخاطر التحالف مع روسيا بحسب قولها
واوضحت المسؤوله الامريكيه انها طلبت لقاء
الرئيس المحتجز محمد بازوم لكنها لم تتمكن
من ذلك واكدت انها ارادت ان توضح لقاده
الانقلاب تاثير عدم استعاده الديمقراطيه
على العلاقه مع واشنطن
[موسيقى]
ارحب بضيوفي في هذه الحلقه من السفيره
سوزان بيج وهي نائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق للشؤون الافريقيه
ومن ميلانو كويتي مدير كليه البحوث بمركز
كوفي عنان الدولي للتدريب على حفظ السلام
ومن باريس
وهي مديره معهد اليقظه لدراسات العلاقات
الدوليه والاستراتيجيه والخبيره في الشان
الافريقي اهلا بكم ابدى بضيفه من السفيره
سوزان عن هذا اللقاء اللافت بين المبعوث
الامريكيه وقاده الانقلاب في النيجر ماذا
حملت نولاند في هذا التوقيت بالذات
للعاصمه ميامي
حسب فهمي ان ان رغبه اداره بايدن هي كانت
مناقشه المناقشه مع قاده الانقلاب لمعرفه
ما هي النواياهم مع التركيز طبعا على
محاوله اعاده الرئيس المنتخب الديمقراطيه
معزوم
بطريقه سلميه على ما نامل اذا ما قعدنا
توصيف الموقف الامريكي مما جرى في النيجر
الى الان واشنطن لا تسمي ما جرى في واشنطن
بالانقلاب وبالتالي ما تصور ما حملته
لنيابه على صعيد تصور الحل كيفيه العوده
الى المسار الدستوري في نيامي
انا حسب فهمي
ان الرغبه هي كانت اجراء
محدثات صريحه
فمن المجاز اللي قدمته وهي قالت تكافل
محادثات صعبه جدا لكنها كانت صريحه ايضا
وان بعض المساعده فعلا جرى تعليق
المساعدات المقدمه من ولايه المتحده
للنيجر ولكن هل انهم اشاروا او التحدث عن
موضوع
شروط الانقلاب او انقلاب ضمن مواصفات
محدده جمع عمليات وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه وهو حسب قانون التخصيصات
ويبقى الاداره هل تقرر تسجيل سيره هذا
الموضوع معهم ام لا لكن الرغبه حسب فهمي
هي اعاده النظام الدستوري الى البلاد هو
مواصله العمل مع حكومه نيجيريا
وايضا لاعاده رئيس باسوم الى السلطه او
على الاقل ان تعود على الاقل اداره مدنيه
الى الرئاسه هذا كان هو محور الحوار هذا
سؤال ضيفته من
موقف باريس الواضح حيال ما يجري في النيجر
تصفه
بالانقلاب ليس كما توصيف واشنطن حتى الان
لما يجري في النيجر وايضا باريس مع تدخل
عسكري من قبل الاكواس لاعاده ما تقول بانه
الشرعيه في النيجر وبالتالي باعتقادك كيف
ترى باريس لهذا التحرك الامريكي مع هذا
الاختلاف نوعا ما في المقاربه الامريكيه
والمقاربه الفرنسيه حتى الان في كيفيه
اعاده الشرعيه
في الحقيقه هناك صعوبه بالغه في التعبير
عن الموقف في فرنسا اليوم فرنسا متشدده في
موقفها نعم لم تبدا فرنسا بمفاوضات ولم
تفتح قنوات الاتصال مع المجلس العسكري كما
فعلت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي
اللحظه الراهنه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه استلمت زمام المبادره بالنسبه
الى هذا الملف الولايات المتحده دخلت في
هذه العمليه بحسب ما نراه وايضا المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا تلعب دورا
وكما تفضلت
السفيره انا اعرف ان اعودت بازون وهو ما
تعرفه السيده نولاند ان عوده بازون صعب
للغايه لذلك يجب النظر في الظروف التي
تسمح بالتفاوض العسكريين من دون القول ان
هذا الانقلاب قد نجح او هذا انقلاب اذا
سوف يكون من الصعوبه مكان انذاك على
الولايات المتحده ان تستمر في عملها هذا
برايه ما قامت به السيده نولد باضافه الى
ذلك لارادت ان تفتح هذا الخط الاتصال مع
العسكريين كي لا تاتي مجموعه الى
النيجر باضافه الى التواجد الامريكي
العسكري في النيجر الا يتاثر بهذا
الانقلاب بعد ذلك يجب ان نرى كيفيه المضي
قدما في المفاوضات هناك النقاط شائكه
بالنسبه الى النقاط المرتبطه
بالتعاون
مع مالي وبوركينا فاسو وهناك نقاط قيد
التفاوض اعتقد انه سوف نتمكن من المضي
قدما من دون تدخل عسكري
بالنقاط الصعبه ايضا ذكرته السيده نولد
بالقول بانها اجرت محادثات صعبه وانا
سؤالي ضيفي من ميلانو السيد ايمانويل من
حيث توقيت هذه الزياره لهذه المسؤوله
الامريكيه وحديث عن مفاوضات صعبه مع
العسكريين باعتقادك هل نجحت في نزع فتيل
التدخل العسكري ام علينا ان ننتظر
اعتقد
ان زياره قامت بها السيده نولاند مفيده
جدا
وهي مفيده
لانني اعتقد ان اخوه كانوا متسرعين جدا
بالتهديد بالتدخل العسكري
وبعد هذا التهديد وبعد انتهاء المهدي
المهده التي قدمها
اصبح من الواضح ان بحاجه الى
الانسحاب قليلا
وان هذه العمليه العمليه التي بدات
الحكومه الامريكيه
بارسال السيده نولان
وهذه طريقه جيده وان اداره بايدن تستجنب
استغنى كلمه انقلاب
او لذلك على امل ان افضل خيار هو
التفاوضي لشعب النيجر وفي هذه الاحاديث او
التبادل الحديث جميع
يتحدثون وكانهم قدموا
فضلا او قام ولديهم فضل على النيجر
ويقومون بمنه على النيجر لكن واضحا ان
القرار فيما يتعلق كيف تحكم النيجر نفسها
هو فقط مسؤوليه الشعب النيجاري ولا غيرهم
وكل الاطراف المعنيه الاخرى
بامكانها فقط ان تساعد شعب النيجر على ان
تقرير هل ان السيد بازوني يعود السلطه او
هناك نظام دستوري
سيد ايمانويل انت في ايطاليا ايطاليا
موقفها واضح ضد اي تدخل عسكري في النيجر
في المقابل لدينا ايضا فرنسا مع التدخل
العسكري ومع نواشنطن وزياره هذه المسؤوله
الرفيعه في الخارجيه الامريكيه واشنطن
نوعا ما موقفها يختلف عن الموقفين
باعتقادك بهذه الزياره هل ترجح ان مساله
الحل العسكري اصبحت ابعد الان هناك فرصه
للتفاوض من خلال هذه الزياره
نعم نعم هذا هو المغزى والمقصد لان
ما هي المصلحه
المصنع ان الدوره فرنسا كانت توافق او لا
توافق ليس مهم
وهذا النوع بالضبط من السلوك التي تقوم به
فرنسا هو الذي يفتح فيه يعرف كل منطقه الى
ديناكيه جديده
وان هذه الزياره السيد مهمه وقد حسب رايي
منعت التدخل العسكري وهو
ما كان مشينا يساعد اي طرف وبالتالي ننظر
الى الخيار السلمي وبالتدخل هناك شيئين
لابد ان نتاكد منهما اولهما فهمه المجتمع
والسياق الذي نريد التدخل فيه وثانيا
التاكد بان كل
الموجودون كل الموجودين
سيبتعدون عن النفوذ او التاثيرات الخارجيه
في هذه الحاله اسال ضيفتي من السفيره
سوزان
العسكريون في النيجر باستقبالهم للسيده
نولد كان في هذا الوفد من الاتحاد
الافريقي رفضوا له وكذلك من الاقواس
ورفضوا استقباله واستقبلوا السيده نولاند
وبالتالي ما الاوراق التي تملكها واشنطن
حيال الازمه الحاليه في نيامي تمكنها من
ان تلعب دورا مؤثرا في تجنب اي سيناريو
كارثي في هذا البلد
اعتقد ان فكر الفكره وراء ليس فقط
زياره
مساعده
الوزير نولاندا هي لمحاوله اجراء محادثات
دبلوماسيه والتاكد انه قبل اي تدخل عسكري
هناك
حوار حقيقي وتبادل الكلام حقيقي على امل
يتجنب التدخل العسكري هل هذا هو الحال ام
لا علينا ان ننتظر لنرى ولكنني اعتقد
القائد العسكريين حاليا للنيجر
فريسه سيده هناك تساؤل وطرحه ضيفي قبل
قليل من ميلانو عن لماذا التسرع في
الذهاب واللجوء الى الحل العسكري فيما
يتعلق بما يجري في انيامي يتساءل حدث
انقلاب في مالي وحدث انقلاب في بوركينا
فاسو وحدث انقلاب في افريقيا الوسطى ولم
يتم نفس
السيناريو ما سر هذا الاهتمام الدولي
والتركيز الدولي عندما يتعلق الامر بهذا
الانقلاب الذي جرى في ميامي ما تفسير ذلك
انه ببساطه بالنسبه الى القاده الافريقيين
هناك تراكم نحن نتحدث عن خامس انقلاب
عسكري في اقل من ثلاث سنوات لذلك هذا
التراكم ادى الى تلك النتيجه تراكم
الانقلابات وايضا بالنسبه الى رئاسه
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
الرئيس النيجيري اراد ان يقول ان زعزعه
الاستقرار من خلال الانقلابات تؤثر سلبا
على غرب افريقيا هذا هو موقف المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا والذي يصبح
الضعف اذا برايي المجموعه ان الانقلابات
غير الدستوريه
على المقاطعه سيده بارين
هناك من يقول حتى بشكل علني
من قام بالانقلاب في اليامي يتهم دوله
وصفها بالعظمى وهنا الاشاره الى كما يرى
الكثيرون الاشاره الى فرنسا انها هي من
تدفع باتجاه الحل العسكري والتدخل العسكري
وانها هيمن تضغط على الايكواس من اجل الحل
العسكري في النيجر وبالتالي لماذا النيجر
ولم يحدث ذلك الذي بوركينا فاسو ولا في
مالي
ولكن اعتقد انه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن امرين
اولا قرار القاده الافريقيين الذين راوا
سلسله الانقلابات العسكريه تلك والذين
يخشون ان هذه الانقلابات سوف تصل الى
دارهم في نهايه المطاف وثانيا الموقف
الفرنسي فرنسا التي تخشى اعاده السيناريو
الذي حصل في مالي
ووصول روسيا وتمدد النفوذ الروسي في تلك
المنطقه ودفع فرنسا خارجا اذا نتحدث عن
هدفين
والنتيجه التراكميه
وان المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول الغرب
افريقيا رفعت السقف وليس لديها القدرات
لتتدخل ولا يمكنها ان تتدخل من دون دعم
على الاقل من خلال الدعم الاستخبا من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفرنسا عندما
تقول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه دعونا
نتوقف قليلا ونفضل الحل الدبلوماسيه ما من
تدخل العسكري الممكن من قبل المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا في انتظار
انتهاء المفاوضات مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في الفتره الراهنه التدخل
العسكري لا يمكن ان يتم من دون الدعم
الفرنسي والامريكي طيب دعم الفرنسي
والامريكي وهنا والسيد ايمانويل عن
المقاربه الفرنسيه فيما يجري في النيجر
والمقاربه الامريكيه هناك تباينت فعلي
بدايه لماذا
هذه المقاربات الدوليه عندما يتعلق الامر
بالنيجر ليس كما جرى في مالي او في
بوركينا فاسو بناء على هذين المنظرين
الفرنسي من جهه والامريكي من جهه برايك
السيد ايمانويل
اعتقد
فرنسا لديها مفهوم وعدم اهتمامه وتحسس
باحتياجات
والقضايا الهامه في النيجر
اما الولايات المتحده فهي لا لا تدعم
الانقلاب الولايات المتحده
تفهم
مركزيه واهميه
النيجر في مكافحه الارهاب
والولايات المتحده تستخدم اسلوبا اكثر
نظجا
دعونا نجري حديثا دعونا نتبادل الكلام
لنصل الى وضع يكون الجميع في فائزون ولكن
فرنسا لطالما شاعره بان
مستعمراتها السابقه ليس لديها اي حقبه
تنتقد قرارات مستقله بحد ذاتها
[موسيقى]
اذا هناك فهم
الامر يتطلب فهما جيدا
لمدى تعقد المشكله النيجيريه هو هذا يدفع
الولايات المتحده
واما الدول الاخوه لا كان كان عليهم ان
يستخدموا اسلوبا او منهجا ذكرت ذلك قبل
قليل الايمان
على ما ادت به من تصريحه السيده نولاند
عقب لقائها
بالعسكريين في انيامي محدده المحاذير
الامريكيه بما اسمته التحالف او التقارب
مع روسيا وكذلك اهميه العوده الى المسار
الديمقراطي في النيابه من خلال هذه
المحددات هل نفهم بان المقاربه الامريكيه
قائمه على العوده الى المسارات الديمقراطي
ليس بالضروره اعاده الرئيس
بازو والا تتحالف نيامي مع روسيا هل هذه
المحددات هذا هو سيناريو الامريكيه
المقترح
اعتقد ان علينا ان نتجنب
الدخول في مساله التنافس القوى العظمى مع
روسيا ثم او فيما يتعلق بمجموعه فاكنار من
الواضح ان مجموعه فاكنار تعمل في عدد من
الدول وحسب فهمي فعلا حصل بعض الاتصال من
قبل بمجموعه
بالقاده العسكريين في النيجر
ولكنني اعتقد انما تريد الولايات المتحده
حقا هو ولكن
عذرا على المقاطعه ولكن هذا ما صرحت به
السيده نولاند حذرت من خطوره التقارب مع
روسيا
طبعا طبعا لا يريدونه من يتقربوا الى
روسيا ولكن الفكره ما تريده حقا الولايات
المتحده هو تجنب وحصول حرب اما بقياده
الاكواس او بقياده
باريس او اي طرف اخر بل يردون فقط العوده
النظام الدستوري حتى لو كان ذلك لا يعني
بالضروره عوده بازون الى السلطه
حله محله قياده مدنيه طيب في هذه الحاله
اسال ضيفه
عن الان عن ارجح السيناريوهات في ظل كل
هذه التطورات هناك اجتماع مرتقب لقاده
ايكواس هناك جهود امريكيه نوعيه من خلال
زياره السيده ولقائها بالعسكريين في
النيامي وبالتالي اي سيناريوهات ترجحين
الاقرب للتنفيذ المؤشرات تقول انه رب ما
يكون تدخل عسكري في اي لحظه في المقابل
هناك معطيات اخرى ماذا ترجحين
اعتقد ان التدخل العسكري يبتعد وليست
بالفكره المنطقيه والجميع يعرف ذلك اذا
بالنسبه الى موضوع تدخل العسكري اعتقد انه
يمكننا ان نتنفس الصعداء لان تاجيل
امكانيه الدخول في هذا الحل ادى الى اراحه
الاطراف اعتقد انه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن
مفاوضات طويله المدى اليوم
المجلس العسكري رفض
الاكواس ورفض وساطه الاتحاد الافريقي
وايضا اغلاق الحدود شكرا وايضا هناك
عقوبات شكرا لك واعتذر منك وقد ادركنا
الوقت
اليقظه لدراسات العلاقات الدوليه من باريس
وكذلك الشكر لضيف من ميلانو ايمان الكويسي
انج مدير كليه البحوث مركز كوفي عنان
الدولي للتدريب على حفظ السلام وكذلك
لضيفه من ميشيغن السفيره سوزان بيج نائبه
مساعد وزير الخ ارجيه الامريكيه السابق
للشؤون الافريقيه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]